thank you
[Music]
so we're going to talk about Masha amini
she is the uh I believe she was 22 years
old she's an Iranian woman who uh was
caught by the morality police oh for not
wearing her hijab correctly do they have
a fashion police out there too in Iran
what they are but I mean out of any type
of fashion police these would be the
most brutal they took her and they were
going to take her to like one of those
centers where they kind of re-educate
you on the thing that you [ __ ] up on
this is what a good Muslim woman does
yeah and then instead she ended up dead
oh oh [ __ ] and they're saying that
um this is the official authorities are
saying that no she just suffered a heart
attack out of nowhere
um but she had no existing heart
conditions she's also really young and
uh yeah they are everyone believes
they're lying and now there's huge
unrest in several different countries
and cities there's protests going on
right now and because we have the stupid
American luxury of protesting to
absolutely no real consequence out there
there's at least 30 protesters that have
been killed up to this point like
morality because they're burning hijabs
they're burning uh pictures of the of
the Iranian leader they're they're going
off and they're getting killed over it
yeah I saw a video yesterday on Reddit
of the Iranian National Guard pulling
out AKs and shooting into the crowd oh
they were blasting just protesters
they're just killing the women out there
yeah yeah and then like one of the
morality police Chiefs too uh he got
beat the [ __ ] of he was all bloodied and
also they grabbed they're they're
getting some too they're getting good I
mean they're killing their friends the
girls are trying to stand up for
themselves so the girls are beating the
guys up it's all always around yeah
everyone just beating everybody up yeah
they're men on on the girls side too
absolutely okay because it's not just
like a bunch of ladies like yeah
it's just she got arrested and then now
she's dead and then so everyone's like
well what the [ __ ] was it was it this
the same story did you see
that
uh like they went to the center and
started beating her was it she went
that's the one yeah she went in a coma
like yeah they took and she like
suffered like she was having symptoms of
like severe concussion they finally took
her to the hospital after like an hour
or two of her suffering and she went in
a coma and passed away but I think one
of the friends
um was like asking like what is
happening we didn't need to take her to
the hospital and they were lying saying
oh that ambulance is for someone else
not your friend but it was actually her
friend
um wow and they didn't allow uh her
father to see her when once like once
she was already you know uh and they
when they finally did her body was
completely wrapped up so you couldn't
really tell and then like a mummy yeah
other than her they beat her yeah they
[ __ ] her up then they're trying to
hide it her head and her feet were out
and they said um that that she had
bruises where you actually could see her
wow
that's wild man the question is so they
have these morality please right do they
also have other police or is that like
their police system out there like what
is this morality police group they're
just that morality police is solely for
the I believe like the uh Sharia yeah
the Sharia law to be um they had them in
a presentation
um Malaysia when me and Bart went
um
man was it during Ramadan I forgot what
it was but they were saying like there
are the guys that are here checking IDs
and [ __ ] like that so they don't care if
you're Chinese or a tourist they're
they're looking for
um Muslim kids that are violating their
laws right but they do have crazy laws
like from all the places we performed at
this one was like guys on this side
girls on that side and then they would
say like if a girl comes up and hugs you
like
um you should probably just do like one
of these none of these like none of
these like the American style hug hell
no well we can't we can't go hug yeah
yeah yeah but if they hug if they hug us
it's like just do one of these one of
these things it was like a lot of like a
lot more not just like stage briefing of
the concert but like
these additional rules that you have to
be really conscious of yeah but they're
not like Iran where you're getting your
ass beat because you violated right like
alcohol rules or whatever right like
it's it's a but those are the things
that that seems extreme for an American
but it gets for that I heard is loose
already for a Muslim country yeah so
that's already relaxed so like imagine a
hardcore one like Iran like oh you
didn't wear it right and then they're
beating your ass why do they have to be
like armed and stuff though that's what
I don't get I mean yeah if you're gonna
have that law Place give them a testisk
and educate them if that's what you want
but like you don't need guns and things
to beat people with yeah and who really
knows what goes on in the re-education
yeah I mean like we don't even know yeah
when I I think I've seen a lot of people
uh protesting around the world too and
like trying to I guess bring awareness
to it do you do you know what the
overall goal is is it to get enough
countries involved where other people
have to or humanitarians to go in there
and kind of stop what's going on or it's
it's hard it's really hard to gauge that
because you also have to consider the
fact that whenever something like this
that's kind of more on the anti-muslim
law thing is like it gets really Juiced
hardcore from uh a capitalist
Countryside yeah you know what I mean
like if you're gonna read the news in
the US they're gonna go yeah we got to
get everyone together and stop this [ __ ]
from ever happening again but then I I
don't think there's such a clear
indication of how the people in Iran are
protesting like what what is their
actual real goal for them because
they've had their internet to completely
cut out they can't even it's the crazy
they can't even like uh put out how they
feel like as much as you know it's more
like other news outlets that are filming
them that are getting the info back out
I thought it was pretty nuts already how
the women were taking off their hijabs
and burning them that's insane he was
like whoa because Nadeem was telling us
that
um when he accidentally walked into one
of his cousins or something like that in
the bathroom she did one of these
because then she's all like you can't
see my my face and then like he was like
that's the same thing as like if you
walk into a bad girl and then you see
your boobies you know that's how you you
know you can't see that [ __ ] out there
right so I was like damn that's one
crazy dude didn't you live in a Muslim
country for a minute doing bible stuff
yeah I was a missionary in Iraq holy
[ __ ] yeah I lived there they thought he
was gay because he didn't have a
mustache
isn't that like wouldn't you just be
Marked for Death trying to spread
Christianity in a Muslim country yeah
well I mean that wasn't so the idea of
like being a missionary there was just I
was just living there living my life I
never was there handing out pamphlets
and [ __ ] like I I made relationships
with people in France and they would
come to me and they'd be like you're a
Christian right and they just have
questions yeah because Muslims believe
in Jesus too but I never wanted to cross
the lines I just was there to be their
friends and make relationships I'm a
Christian you're a Muslim kind of thing
and yeah they
a lot of their idea of religion his
religion is based on morality about
being good and like reverence in these
things and at a certain point you can
see like you know so much of this stuff
is just [ __ ] [ __ ] you know like
uh so they're what do you mean by like
so much of it is [ __ ] like what what
specifically that's right and what's
wrong solely based on your behavior
because it happens here in America too
right like yeah
um a lot of churches these days right
now are policing people's social media
and calling that Christian too right
like we have a morality police in a
sense by whatever Church you're
Affiliated to as well but yeah like
there was obviously a lot of splitting
of the Sexes there's like no alcohol in
this so to find alcohol where I was at
was in the Christian village because
Christians are allowed to drink hey hey
jeez my afternoon
Christina because that was his American
Marine girlfriend's name and he's Muslim
but he'd go to the Christian village to
drink all the time and they'd call him
out he's like no I'm a Christian
but it says Christina
so they so there's a lot of loophole
jumping too you know because that's what
I mean by so much of his just [ __ ]
like that's I don't know does that get
you into heaven you know really like any
of this stuff like covering your head I
think long story short it should it's
just human rights like people should be
able to believe and do what they want
not saying anything is right or wrong
but if someone believes in that culture
and you know doesn't want to show their
face and stuff amazing for you if
someone was born there and
people are telling them what to do and
these women just want their own rights I
mean it's that fine line I just I just
feel bad for it I've seen so many videos
I think it's crazy like you were saying
their phones literally don't work they
cut off all their phone services they
can't text their family their friends to
make sure people are safe that's why
like they're so scared one girl like
finally got service to get like a tick
tock video out or something she's just
crying in a room like I can't
communicate with anyone or show what's
going on like none of us can like it's
really scary even Anonymous you know the
hacker group yeah they uh they came in
and uh they took out a ton of Iranian
government websites in an effort to like
help the protesters and help people they
were like shutting down all these
websites we need Elon to give them the
internet that's actually what's
happening right Skynet right
Terminator yeah I think Joe Biden
to announce some [ __ ] to work with
starlink to get them internet access but
then in Iraq I met a guy who spoke
English he learned it from watching
friends and they watched like great like
friends or sarcastic talks like a sitcom
yeah he dressed up like Chandler and
everything but could there be any more
protests
he told me about how he had a girlfriend
but
um her her dad disapproved of it and I
think he caught them in bed together
told me that he had to go to the
hospital for he was hospitalized because
he got beat the [ __ ] up wow and when I
asked about his girlfriend he was shook
like traumatized they killed her they
think they killed her oh yeah so that
was the kind of [ __ ] like I like the
kind of people I was meeting and living
within seeing like what morality means
to them you know it's just such a crazy
idea really like of piety or holding
Hannah has a schoolmate where uh there's
a big Muslim population in England and
she has a schoolmate where
um one of the students
got into a relationship that wasn't okay
by the parents something happened and
the parents killed the kid what it's
called an honor killing I'm killing him
they killed the kid and then
um because they wanted to save you know
whatever morality reason for their
family or whatever but yeah it's some
crazy stuff dude like it's just it's
just the the culture and the rules are
just so different like I don't know man
I think one of the goals obviously is
just to get Justice
for Masa Omni is to get the officials in
the government to admit that what
happened to her was wrong because
they're lying about they're saying
they had no apartment like how she
she's not guilty weak ass heart yeah
youngest heart attack to ever just
randomly happen from a healthy person
getting bruised all over it yeah
like a lot of people think if they don't
study history right they think Iran is
this extremist Nation but it's that's
recent like they were one of the most
secular and for forward nations in the
Middle East if you see pictures from the
60s and before yeah 70s and before
they're like it looks pretty yeah the
cities are so nice they're like modern
right yeah what happened
um just like when you have a dictator in
every country they had someone call The
Shop
um and he was like a puppet leader of
I would say some Western Nations and and
yeah it was Progressive or like it was
prosperous for some not for all because
that's the unfortunate truth about
um new emerging Nations right like you
have a lot of Rich middle class but you
still have poor people that are down and
out it gives perfect opportunity for
crazy ideal is like like extreme ideals
to kind of seep in and then that's where
the uh I think it's homani or something
like that it's Iranian extremist like uh
leader he came in his crew came in
and all of them just it their ideas
spread like wildfire and then they took
over so like Argo is about Argo yeah
yeah yeah or they had all the Americans
and Canadians had to get out I mean when
there's instability or like there are
people who are down and out it's always
perfect opportunity for crazy people to
come in and swoop them up just like just
like Hitler did you know like every
every every every example there's always
somebody that comes in and they're like
oh no one's giving you guys attention
well guess what I'm here to help you and
then they they rally them up and then
they [ __ ] take over that's what
happened in Egypt too they had their
I've got what it was called something
spring Arab Spring that's great yeah and
then the people rose up and pushed out
their longtime dictator but what
happened in that power vacuum they have
a military dictatorship oh yeah and it's
more corrupt than ever yeah
yeah it's it's crazy because like I
understand the uh the different
cultures and how they have things that
they value and they have customs and
stuff uh but I think it's pretty widely
agreed that people shouldn't be killed
over any of these things yeah you know
just as much as like so severe yeah like
it is kind of a funny thing like when
you look at America and how like if you
were burning across publicly you're
probably not going to get killed over it
people probably wish you died and
celebrated like 50 years ago say a lot
of [ __ ] about you I'll kill you at least
you know yeah there's no that's good but
right but they're gonna want you to die
as much as people wanted uh Kaepernick
to die for kneeling at the game you know
but they're not nope there's no
assassins coming after him you know so
it's one of those things where maybe
that's a sign of a failed Society from
another point of view at a different
country but in general it's like that's
not a death sentence and especially if
it is say that it is instead of and
hiding it they know it's they know they
[ __ ] up yeah if if you have to hide it
then you're not like being like
Singapore like yeah we threw him off the
plane that guy's a corrupt politician
Singapore's badass don't be like anyone
who's corrupt we're gonna take them up
on the plane we're gonna throw him out
with no parachute oh you're chewing gum
homie I'm gonna [ __ ] whip your butt
with a freaking leather whip you know
they're straight up they're like that
sounds nice
I'll take it that's how they work though
they're like uh you know corrupt you get
executed that's that's that's the thing
but at least they're honest about it
right it's like yeah that's the main
thing and I think that's where the
Injustice started it's that like well
she just had a heart attack because that
culture already knows that there's a
morality police and they already know
that that's a pretty big deal to like
wear your hijab incorrectly like that's
that's a known thing but then they
didn't sign up for this [ __ ] and that's
where it really is like whoa how the
[ __ ] no one should die for wearing uh
their their hijab incorrectly that's
just ridiculous dude
so hopefully there's a gonna be a lot um
this unrest is going to be fine for the
all the all the rioters and all the uh
protesters is what's crazy that you know
when we think about the luxury of of
having a protest out here even when it's
not peaceful yeah and you're fine uh
looting the REI nothing's gonna happen
to nobody but then and then you see
these and you're like okay that's yeah
that's really the thing right there it's
like they're they're getting killed for
this yeah that's wild man yeah
foreign